et ça c'est majeur le PNA nous
demande
d'étudier les avantages et les
inconvénients les conditions de
possibilité et les avantages et les
inconvénentss d'une modification du
statut du
LOU c'est-à-dire d'envisager d'envisager
de de modifier un statut enfin de passer
d'un statut strictement protégé un un
statut d'espèce
protégé alors c'est ce qui a soyons
clair c'est c'est ce c'est ce qui a
conduit les associations de protection
de la nature à quitter la
table mais en tout cas c'est inscrit
c'est quelque chose que nous devons
faire au cours du
PNA
2è 2è point
qui concerne l'axe 2 et qui a aussi
focalisé
l'intention le
PNA demande au ministère de
l'agriculture et au préfet
coordonnateur avec le préfet
coordonateur d'étudier ENF plus
qu'étudier de
proposer un statut pour le chien de
protection statut qui devrait être
malgré la
résistance soyons clair de nombre de
directions
ministérielles statut qui devrait être
de nature
législative pourquoi parce qu'on avait
deux
options soit on faisait de du bricolage
réglementaire et ça n'aboutisait pas à
grand-chose soit on donnait
véritablement un cadre juridique
au chien de protection qui deviendrait
chien de travail ça ça pourrait régler
des questions qui aujourd'hui se enfin
empoisonne les toutes les communes les
questions de
divagation les questions
d'aboiement il a il y a un juge qui a
trouvé bon de de d'imposer des colliers
anti-aboiement à à des
Patou ce qui quand même et M
connaître les moyens
de mais des questions aussi qui vont qui
empoisonnent ou vont empoisonner ou
pourrai empoisonner la vie des éleveurs
notamment sur les questions de 10 CPE de
chenil au bout de 10 chiens il faut que
vous ayez un un certain nombre de de
enfin un chenil avec des conditions bien
particulière les questions et euh toutes
les questions qui pourraient régler
aujourd'hui les conflits qui sont non
seulement des conflits avec les
promeneurs mais qui sont des conflits à
l'intérieur des villages